well thank you very much secretary
espera
today our nation honors and mourns the
nearly 3,000 lives that were stolen from
us on September 11th 2001 all these
grounds 184 people were murdered when al
Qaeda terrorists overtook American
Airlines flight 77 and crashed it into
the Pentagon for every American to live
through that day the September 11th
attack is seared into our soul it was a
day filled with shock horror sorrow and
righteous fury I vividly remember when I
first heard the news I was sitting at
home watching a major business
television show early that morning Jack
Welch the legendary head of General
Electric was about to be interviewed
when all of a sudden they cut away at
first there were different reports it
was a boiler fire but I knew that
boilers aren't at the top of a building
it was a kitchen explosion in windows on
the world nobody really knew what
happened there was great confusion I was
looking out of a window from a building
at midtown Manhattan directly at the
World Trade Center when I saw a second
plane at a tremendous speed go into the
second tower it was then that I realized
the world was going to change I was no
longer going to be and it could never
ever be that innocent place that I
thought it was soon after I went down to
Ground Zero with men who worked for me
to try to help in any little way that we
could we were not alone
so many others were scattered around
trying to do the same they were all
trying to help but for the families who
join us this is your anniversary of
personal and permanent loss it's the day
that has replayed in your memory a
thousand times of the last kiss the last
phone call the last time hearing those
precious words I love you then the
attack the anguish of knowing your
family member had boarded one of these
flights or was working in the World
Trade Center we're serving right here at
the Pentagon you waited you prayed you
answered that most dreaded call and your
life changed forever
to each of you the first lady and I are
united with you in grief we come here in
the knowledge that we cannot erase the
pain or reverse the evil of that dark
and wretched day but we offer you all
that we have our unwavering loyalty our
undying devotion and our eternal pledge
that your loved ones will never ever be
forgotten 18 years ago the terrorists
struck this Citadel of power and
American strength but the enemy soon
learned that they could not weaken the
spirit of our people in times of
distress the heart of the American
patriot only
wielder Alfredo Gomez Janine
Nicole Gonzalez Mauricio Gonzalez Rosa J
Gonzalez Lynn Kathryn good child
Calvin Joseph Gooding Peter Morgan
Goodrich Harry goodie
Kiran Kumar ready go poop
Kathryn see for a B visa Ben Gordon
steamed Karine Gordon
Sebastian porky Kiran Joseph Orman to
rescue innocent people one such American
was retired Army colonel Rick West
corrala who gave His life on 9/11 Rick
earned the Silver Star and the Purple
Heart for his service in Vietnam he
later became the vice president for
security at Morgan Stanley in the World
Trade Center on the day of the attack
Rick died while leading countless others
to safety his selfless actions saved
approximately 2,700 lives today I'm
honored to announce that we will soon be
awarding the late Rick Rescorla the
presidential citizens medal for his
extraordinary sacrifice though Rick has
left this earth we will ensure that the
memory of his deeds will never ever be
forgotten his memory will forever endure
thank you thank you Rick thank you Rick
Thank You Rick here on the western side
of the Pentagon we saw brave men and
women rush into the fire and race into
these scorching flames to rescue their
colleagues when evil seeks to do us harm
the incredible men and women of the
United States military answer with
unyielding valor and unstoppable resolve
Navy admiral David Thomas crawled
through live wires and helped lift a
wall of debris to save the life of a
colleague as Admiral Thomas remembers it
was the worst day of my life
but the heroism and selflessness regard
I saw that horrible morning is forever
burned in my heart Admiral Thomas
America salutes you and every Patriot
who defied evil that day thank you very
much thank you very much Army Ranger
Chris Braman repeatedly went back inside
the burning building rescuing one
injured person after another
before he entered he said a prayer and
asked God to give him strength and then
he dove into the suffocating smoke and
fumes and flames at the same time Sheila
moody had just prayed that someone would
find her then she heard Chris's voice as
Sheila says God said Chris as her
guardian angel to Sheila and Chris
America is strengthened by your goodness
and your grace and your bravery thank
you very much thank you
thank you very much to fulfill our
unbreakable promise to every survivor
and family of 9/11 earlier this year we
fully reauthorized the Victims
Compensation Fund to the tune of
billions and billions of dollars since
September 11th nearly 6 million young
men and women have joined the United
States Armed Forces they have crossed
seas climb mountains trekked through
deserts and rushed into enemy compounds
to face down the threat of radical
Islamic terrorism nearly seven thousand
servicemembers have laid down their
lives to protect our home our flag and
our American Way of life American
freedom survives only because there are
patriots willing to sacrifice everything
in its defence no tribute is sufficient
to convey the infinite depth of our
nation's gratitude on the solemn day of
remembrance our thoughts also turn to
the 200,000 valiant soldiers sailors
airmen Coast Guardsmen and Marines who
are now at this very moment stationed
overseas we do not seek conflict but if
anyone dares to strike our land we will
respond with the full measure of
American power and the iron will of the
American spirit and that spirit is
unbreakable we had peace talks scheduled
a few days ago I called them off when I
learned that they had killed a great
American soldier from Puerto Rico and 11
other innocent people they thought they
would use this attack to show strength
but actually what they showed is
unrelenting weakness the last four days
we have hit our enemy harder than they
have ever been hit before
and that will continue and if for any
reason they come back to our country we
will go wherever they are and use power
the likes of which the United States has
never used before and I'm not even
talking about nuclear power they will
never have seen anything like what will
happen to them no enemy on earth can
match the overwhelming strength skill
and might of the American armed forces
and we have rebuilt and strengthened in
the last two and a half years spending
seven hundred billion dollars seven
hundred and sixteen billion dollars and
now just approved 738 billion dollars
more money by far than ever spent on our
armed forces you are the fearless
sentinels who stand watch over all that
we cherish and everything we hold sacred
priceless and dear this morning we also
give thanks to the dedicated men and
women at the Department of Homeland
Security their department was created
after 9/11 to help secure our
immigration system and ensure that those
who threaten our people are denied entry
to our shores
we're indebted to every law enforcement
official state local and federal who
devotes their life to keeping America
safe as we gather at this moment and at
this incredible memorial we are reminded
that there is no greater testament to
our fallen heroes than the presence of
their families who knew and loved them
so much among the family members here
today is Stephanie Dunn
her husband Navy commander Patrick
was one of the Patriots who gave his
life right here 18 years ago before he
left that morning Patrick gave Stephanie
a big beautiful kiss then for the first
time he leaned down and kissed her
pregnant stomach Stephanie was just two
months along with their first child
earlier this year their daughter Allie
celebrated her 17th birthday Allie grew
up into a strong truly remarkable young
woman she mentors the children of our
nation's wounded warriors and recently I
was honored to give Allie the
president's volunteer service award for
her hundreds of hours of community
service we are blessed to have Allie
here with us at today's ceremony Thank
You Ali and Ali I know your dad is
watching over you he's right up there
he's watching from heaven looking down
right now with love and pride he is so
proud of you thank you very much
incredible
also joining us is the VG anno family
for generations
the VG anno family has served in our
military and in the New York City Fire
and Police Department's these are two
great departments I grew up with them
I know on September 11th NYPD detective
Joseph VG anno rushed into the World
Trade Center and died rescuing his
fellow citizens his brother John was a
New York firefighter he also gave his
life that day at Ground Zero at the time
Joseph's three sons were just young boys
ages eight six and three months old this
morning they are with us
the youngest John just started his
freshman year of college at SUNY
maritime college and he plans to join
the military Joseph's juniors a marine
reservist and just like his father he is
a proud member of the NYPD and James is
a corporal in the Marines on his last
deployment James was stationed on the
USS New York a ship made using 24 tons
of steel from the World Trade Center
every time he left the mess hall on his
way to his bunk he passed a picture of
his dad to John Joseph and James and to
the vigía no family you have sacrificed
beyond measure and you will never ever
stop giving back to this country and
thank you very much for being here thank
you very much thank you thank you very
proud of you thank you thank you very
much the heroes present today remind us
of an immortal truth the future of our
nation is secured through the vigilance
of our people the brave men and women
who tore through the game
of Hell to save the hurt and the wounded
the servicemembers who honor the friends
who perished by continuing their
exceptional life of service the moms and
dads who endure the loss of their soul
mates and fill their children's lives
with all of the adoration in the world
the sons and daughters who suffered
grave loss and yet through it all
persevere to care for our neighbors
defend our homeland and safeguard our
nation each of your lives tells the
story of courage and character virtue
and valor resilience and resolve loyalty
and love this morning we make a sacred
vow to carry on this noble legacy today
and every day we pledge to honor our
history to treasure our Liberty to
uplift our communities to live up to our
values to prove worthy of our heroes and
above all stronger than ever to never
ever forget we are now and will forever
be one American family united by
patriotism bound by destiny and
sustained by the faith of Almighty God
thank you god bless you god bless our
military and god bless the United States
of America thank you all thank you very
much
ladies and gentlemen please render
honors for the plane of taps
[Music]
[Music]
recall
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen this concludes
today's the thank you for joining us
this morning